สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะ
นักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
มีแล้วหรอคะ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 7 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 9
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 200 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้ด้วยเวลา
5 ทุ่ม
นาที
47 นาทีค่ะ
23:47 นก็เป็นเวลา
กลางคืนเป็นตอนกลางคืน
เป็น
วันจันทร์ใช่ไหมคะคืนวันจันทร์
เป็นวันแรกเนาะวันจันทร์เนี่ยก็เป็นวัน
แรกที่ครูฟ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยทำงานเพราะว่า
เมื่อวานเนี่ยอาทิตย์แล้วก็เมื่อวันซืน
วันเสาร์เนี่ย
เป็นวันหยุดแต่จริงๆครูฟ้าหยุดใช่ไหมทำ
งานทุกวัน
7 วัน
คือทำงานหนักนะคะ
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนตอนครูฟ้า
เนี่ยอยู่ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมครูฟ้าทำงานที่
บ้านทำงานที่บ้านแต่ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าไม่ได้
อยู่ประเทศไทยแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เขาพายเรือไปออสเตรเลียแล้วนะคะนักเรียน
เขาพายเรือจากประเทศไทยแล้วก็
ไปออสเตรเลียใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะพายเรือจากไทย
ไปออสเตรเลีย
ใช้เวลา
10 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหม
ถึงแล้ว
เร็วมาก
ไม่ใช่เหรอคะ
ไม่ใช่ครูฟ้านั่งเครื่องบินใช่ไหมนั่ง
เครื่องบินไป
ออสเตรเลียแล้วใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ชีวิตของครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยก็เปลี่ยน
เมื่อก่อนอยู่ประเทศไทยทำงานที่บ้านใช่
ไหมอันนี้เป็นเตียงนอน
ภูฟ้านอนแล้วก็ตื่นมาตื่น
นั่งโต๊ะทำงาน
ก็คือครูฟ้าไปทำงานด้วยกันเดิน
ตื่นปุ๊บเดินแล้วก็ทำงาน
ง่ายมากนะคะคือว่าทำงานง่ายๆไม่เหนื่อย
ใช่ไหมใช่ครูฟ้าถ้าครูฟ้าทำงาน 10 โมงครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น
9 โมง 45 ก็มีเวลาเยอะ
มันก็เลยตื่น 9 โมง 55 นะคะที่จริงแล้ว
เนี่ย
ขอเวลา 5 นาทีหาแว่นตาเท่านั้น
ได้เลยแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยไม่เหมือนเดิมแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ได้ทำงานที่บ้านค่ะ
ถ้าอันนี้คือบ้านของครูฟ้าแล้วก็เป็นถนน
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็อาจจะแบบดูปิงก็ไม่รู้นะคะ
ถนนถนน
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าก็มาทำงานที่นี่ใช่ไหม
อาจจะเป็น
ร้านอาหาร
ร้านอาหารไทยครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำไม่ได้ทำอาหาร
นะคะทำงานที่ร้านอาหารไทยก็คือครูฟ้าเป็น
แม่ครัวไหมคะเป็นแม่ครัว
ฟ้าเป็นแม่ครัวทำอาหารใช่ไหม
โอเคไหม
คิดว่าถ้าคนออสเตรเลียกินอาหารที่ครูฟ้า
ทำก็คงคิดอร่อยเออแต่ก็ไม่นะคนออสเตรเลีย
อาจจะเคยมาประเทศไทยกินอาหารไทยแบบ
Original แล้วครูฟ้าก็ทำอาหารนะ
ใช่แต่
จริงที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยอาหารไทยอร่อยนะคะ
ร้านที่ครูบอยทำ
นี่คือฟ้าทำงาน
อาหารไทย The  Best อร่อยมากกว่าประเทศ
ไทยบางอย่าง
มากินแล้วถ้าครูฟ้าบอกว่าอาหารไทยที่ร้าน
อาหารไทยอะไรเนี่ยอาหารไทยในร้านอาหารไทย
ที่ครูฟ้าทำงานเนี่ยอร่อยก็งั้นครูฟ้าก็
ไม่ใช่แม่ครัวไม่ได้เป็นคนทำอาหาร
ทำไมคะ
รักคุณฟ้าทำอาหารตัวเองแล้วจะบอกว่า
ไม่ได้เป็นแม่ครัวค่ะคุณหญิงสีแดงไปไหนคะ
ทำอะไรถูพื้น
ใช่
มะ
2 ข้างเลยหรอคะคุณฟ้า
อันนี้ครูฟ้าวาดรูป
อ๋อตกใจนะคะคือคือไม่ใช่ว่าครูฟ้าทำไม่
ได้นะคะผู้หญิงแค่คิดว่าถ้าครูฟ้าเสิร์ฟ
มือซ้ายก็มีอาหารมีถาดอาหารมือขวาก็มีถาด
อาหารกูฟเดินๆๆไม่ถึงลูกค้าค่ะ
เป็นพนักงานเสิร์ฟ
แต่ว่าเพราะครูฟ้ายังทำงานได้ไม่นานไงถ้า
ครูฟ้าทำงานนานๆครูฟ้าก็อาจจะเสิร์ฟ 2
มือได้นะเก่งแล้วแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าทำ
งานนิดหน่อยแล้วบ้านเนาะ
ไปถึงร้านอาหารเนี่ยใกล้หรือว่าไกลคะ
แป๊บนึงนะ
เช็คว่า
จากบ้านคู่ฟ้าไปถึงร้านอาหารเนี่ยกี่
กิโลเมตรใช่ไหม
ใช่
แต่
บอกว่าที่อเมริกาอินเทอร์เน็ตดีมากครู
หญิงโหลดวีดีโอส่งวีดีโอผ่าน Google
Drive อ่ะค่ะวิดีโอ 45 นาที
ใช้เวลาประมาณ
1-2 นาทีเสร็จแล้วอ่ะตอนอยู่ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยน่าจะประมาณ 5 นาทีมั้ง
ดีจริงๆ
แต่ว่าอินเทอร์เน็ตโทรศัพท์ไม่โอเคนะ
ร้านอาหารกับบ้านของครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะมัน
.5 กิโลเมตร
อุ๊ย
ก็เดินได้นี่
ไม่ได้ค่ะไกล
อ๋อไกลใช่ไหมไม่งั้นเวลาครูฟ้าจะไปทำงาน
ครูฟ้าก็ไม่ได้เดินไม่ใช่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เดินต๊อกๆๆ
จากบ้านไปร้านอาหารเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ได้เดิน
ไปใช่ไหมคะ 32 นาที
32 นาที
เดินหรือว่าขับรถหรือว่านั่งรถเดินเดิน
ไม่ไกลมากมันก็ 2.5 กิโลก็โอเคแหละแต่ว่า
เดินไม่โอเคนะคะ
ไปทำงานยังไงคะทุกวันเนี่ยไปทำงานเดินทาง
ไปทำงานเหมือนๆกันไหม
บางทีที่บ้านครูฟังแล้วเนี่ยนะคะมีรถ
หูฟังใช่ไหม
ไม่ได้วาดนานไง
มีรถกี่คันน่ะ
มีพี่ชายใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
บางทีก็ขับรถแล้วก็เบิก
ขับรถไปส่ง
รถค่ะ
2.5 กิโลเมตรเนี่ยใช้เวลากี่นาทีอ่ะคะ
ถึง 8 นาที
เร็วนะใกล้นะคือถ้าคิดกรุงเทพฯบางครั้ง
กรุงเทพฯถ้าบ้านกับออฟฟิศ 2.5 กิโลเมตร
ขับรถไปอาจจะได้แบบ 30 นาทีได้นะ
[เพลง]
คะก็โอเคแต่ว่าถ้าพี่ชายครูฟ้า
ให้ขับรถไปส่งใช่ไหมพี่ชายครูฟ้าก็ทำงาน
นะคะ
ก็จะต้อง
เดินไปเองครูฟ้าต้องไปทำงานเอง
มันก็จะเดินใช่แล้วก็เดินมันจะมี
อะไรคะ
รถบัสค่ะ
แต่ว่าป้ายรถเมล์ใช่ไหม
ตอนแรกผู้หญิงคือฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้าวาดหัวใจ
ทำไมงงมากนะคะอ๋อ
พอเดินก็จะเดินมารอรถเมล์อ่ะถ้าสมมุติว่า
ครูฟ้าทำงานเนี่ย
10 โมงสมัยสมมุตินะครูฟ้าทำงานที่ร้าน
อาหาร 10 โมงครูฟ้าต้องเดินมารอรถเมล์ตอน
กี่โมงอ่ะคะ
จริงๆรถบัสรถเมล์ที่นี่เนี่ยมันน้อยนะคะ
ใกล้ๆบ้านเนี่ย
เอาไว้เช็คเกี่ยวกับรถนะคะว่าเบอร์
นัมเบอร์อะไรใช่ไหมแล้วก็ไปที่ไหน
[เพลง]
รู้สึกว่า 1 ชั่วโมง
1 คัน
สมมุติว่ารถบัสมาใช่ไหมคะนักเรียน
รถบัสมา
แล้วก็มาตอน
pm
บ่าย 3 โมง
อ้าบ่าย 3 โมงรถบัสมาบ่าย 3 โมงแล้วก็รถ
บัสบรื่นบ๊ายบายก็จะมาอีกทีอ้าวแล้วกดผิด
ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยกำลังเดินเดินเดินอยู่ใช่
ไหมเดินอยู่ที่นี่แล้วรถบัสครูฟ้าเห็นรถ
เมล์อยู่ตรงนั้นแล้วแล้วรถเมล์กำลังจะออก
ไป
ครูฟ้าครูฝากวิ่งๆๆ
นี้
ครูฟ้าต้องรออีก 1 ชั่วโมงนะ
จะง่ายกว่านะคะถ้าสำหรับการ
ครูฟ้าต้องเรียน
พี่ชายครูฟ้าจะให้ครูฟ้าเรียนขับรถอยู่นะ
คะ
[เพลง]
ไม่โอเคเลยเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำงาน
5 โมงเย็น
เวลามันไม่โอเคก็มีนะ
คะแบบ
คือถ้า 4 โมงคือทุกวันทุกวันก็คือ 4 โมง 4
โมง 4 โมงเราจะรู้เวลาอยู่แล้วใช่ไหมว่า 1
ชั่วโมงทันมากี่โมง
บางทีก็อาจจะ 3 โมง
[เพลง]
มันจะประมาณนี้แหละหรือว่า 4 โมงซัก 4
โมง
5 นาที
จะเลทนิดหน่อยเร็วกว่านิดหน่อยเรทนิด
หน่อย
ถ้างั้นเราก็ต้องมาถึงก่อนก่อนรถเนี่ย
สักประมาณ 30 นาทีได้ไหม
ไม่ใช่คิด
10 นาทีไม่ถึงแต่ว่าใช้เวลาเนาะเราอาจจะ
เวลาประมาณแบบ
สมมุติ 3 โมง 50 จนถึง 4 โมง 5 ก็ประมาณ
15 นาทีที่เราอาจจะต้องยืนรอรถใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่โอเคเพราะว่าหนาว
แล้วถ้ารถบัสเนี่ยเขามาถึงป้ายรถเมล์แล้ว
เนี่ยหรือว่ารถเมล์เนาะคนไทยเรียกรถเมล์
นะคะครูฟ้าเขาต้องเปลี่ยนเพราะว่าที่
ออสเตรเลียเขาไม่เรียกรถเมล์กันนะคะแต่
ที่ไทยเนี่ยเรียกรถเมล์ใช่ไหมรถเมล์ที่
ออสเตรเลีย
คือกรุงเทพฯอ่ะประเทศไทยมันต้องโบกไงหรือ
ว่าอันนี้ไม่ต้องโบกเขาจอดถูกป้ายอยู่
แล้วใช่ค่ะเขาจอดรถบัสเนี่ยไม่ต้องโบก
ไม่ต้องนะคะเดี๋ยวเขาจะมาจอดเอง
ถ้าจากรถ
ไปถึงที่ทำงานครูฟ้ารถเมล์มาแล้วครูฟ้า
ขึ้นรถเมล์แล้วเนี่ยไปถึงที่ทำงานเนี่ย
ใช้เวลาน่าจะประมาณ
4 นาที 5 นาทีไหมก็ถึงแล้ว
ประมาณ 4 นาทีถึง 5 นาที
[เพลง]
ถ้าบางคนบางประเทศเนี่ย 30 นาทีเดินสบายๆ
ใช่ไหมคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเดินคิดว่าครู
ฟ้าเนี่ย
มันหนาวไง
โอเคถ้า
ไปทำงานก็ใกล้ๆเออแต่ว่ารถนิดหน่อยรถบัส
นิดหน่อย
บางทีมันไม่โอเครถนิดหน่อย
ถ้าพี่ชายไปส่งแล้วก็ทำงานเสร็จแต่ว่าถ้า
ทำงานเสร็จแล้วกลับบ้านเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ไม่
นั่งรถบัสไหม
ไม่มีค่ะรถบัสซื้อออสเตรเลียหรอ
น่าจะ
9:00 นก็หมดละ
[เพลง]
Noble ไม่มีแล้วค่ะไม่มีรถบัส 3 ทุ่ม
ครึ่งไม่มีรถบัสแล้ว
หมด
พี่ชายก็ต้องขับรถมารับครูฟ้า
ที่ร้านอาหารใช่ไหมแล้วก็กลับบ้านด้วยกัน
ที่เมืองที่ครูฟ้าอยู่เนี่ยก็ขับรถไปทำ
งานขับรถไปเรียนใช่ไหมว่าครูฟ้าก็เรียน
ด้วยก็ง่ายกว่านั่งรถเมล์นะเพราะว่ารถ
เมล์เนี่ยใช้เวลารอรอนะคะนานมากๆอ่ะมันมี
น้อยไงอะไรคะ
รถค่ะ
ลดมาคิดว่ามันโอเคกว่า
ครูฟ้าต้องเรียนขับรถแล้วค่ะเรียนขับรถ
เพราะว่า candara เนี่ยฟ้าอยู่เมือง
แคนเบอร์รานะคะแคมเบอร์ล่ารถบัสนิดหน่อย
มี tram  P นะ
คะก็
มีรถ tram แหละแต่ว่า
ไม่เยอะไม่เยอะมันก็ไกลจากบ้านแล้วก็ไปรถ
บัส
ต้องเป็นแบบเมืองจริงๆที่คนเนี่ยไม่ค่อย
ขับรถก็จะมีรสเค็มมากๆใช่ไหม
นั่นแหละแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนที่ทำ
งานที่ไม่ได้ทำงานที่บ้านเนี่ยนักเรียน
เนี่ยไปทำงานยังไงก็คอมเมนต์คุยกับเราได้
นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้คุณหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อน
แล้วเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะ
นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]
บ๊ายบาย